people living in Kaunas burg in what's
now Russian Poland hard to say which
they had seven bridges across two shores
of the prego river and there's two
islands one island here in Island over
here there's a bank over here Bank over
here and they've got it set up so that
there are seven bridges one two so you
could go you know you walk over this way
you could take a horse and buggy over to
that side cross over here cross over
here and cross over here one two three
four five six seven bridges people
argued can you take a Sunday walk and
just cross every bridge once so I want
to go up some day and just walk across
this bridge walk across this bridge walk
this bridge oh I'll go this way this
time walk across here walk across here
oops I can't do it because I'm I've
already crossed those and I've left one
I don't care where I start and where I
stop but can I cross every bridge one
time people argued about it nobody was
able to do it
oilers in st. Petersburg working for the
Zara's and he hears about this problem
and up until then people had said well
we have to make a list of all possible
ways to do this we have to try here go
there at the new visibility of it and in
this wonderful paper that Euler writes
he says trying to solve it one at a time
doesn't tell us anything new
it's what today we would call a
numerical solution that might give you
an answer but it doesn't give you
understanding he's saying how do I do
this huh and then he says think about
ordinary bridges every time I walk
across a bridge onto an island I go from
blue to polka dot land Oh blue to polka
dot land polka dot land to red the red
shirt over to polka dot lay or okay
oiler rather than concentrating on the
bridges
start saying look at the islands look at
the landmasses let's label those and
think about that so he goes over and
says I'll label him oh okay I'll label
what I call polka dot fill I'll call
that a well reach in my pocket call this
B over here over here this side let's
call it C and oh look at this
there's D I should I shouldn't be
walking in the water I should just stay
on the in fact I can't do that I oughta
just stay on the bridges the whole time
keep me honest you're Brady um
Oh Papa Papa let's make it real simple
if I have nothing but a bridge going
from C to D to B they start from C to D
buh buh buh pup up up up up okay that's
legal so I have C D they go from D to B
oh it's dB every time I get from one to
another from one land mass to another
land mass I can make a list of my
travels but those are our books stay out
of the water oiler says this means that
if I have an even number of bridges one
one going to into and out of an island
that's completely legal I can go right
through the island if I have to or if I
have four bridges oh I can come across
here come across here back over and back
but an odd number of bridges okay I can
come across here and come across here
but I'm stuck go this way turn around
but I haven't crossed this one
alternatively I could start on yellow on
D walk this way
come back here and then walk out here
oiler says
oh if I have an odd number of bridges to
any or from any island I have to either
start my walk at that location or ends
my walk at that location right now Isle
into a has two bridges going to it that
means oh if I do not start on this
island I can just traverse it an oiler
goes on and says and if I start on that
island I can go around blah blah a
little Villanova and return to it even
numbered islands islands that have an
even number of bridges going to them
I've got it made this makes it possible
for me to to to almost eliminate them
from my thought process and it works
whether it's two four or even or even
six okay got that one any landmasses any
any place that has bridge connecting to
it if it has an even number of bridges
ah easy piece of cake
if it has an odd number of bridges then
it's a special case clearly if there's
just one land mass that has an odd
number of bridges I can start on it but
I won't be able to get back to it to
stop on it but if I have two islands
that have an odd number of bridges
leading to them I can start on one
traverse around and then end on the
other one now let's go back to what was
really happening in kind of Berg around
1725 seven bridges remember wasn't
arranged like this it was one two three
four five six seven okay let me see what
la Papa Papa let me see how I'm doing
this section this the red shore what I'm
caught what he calls see I have one two
three bridges from oh oh it's an
number odd number okay how about D let's
go over it Island D one two three
bridges oh this is odd how about the
North Shore be one two three odd number
what about island eight one two three
four five an odd number all of these
land masses have an odd number of
bridges leading to them oiler says uh uh
none of them have an even number of
bridges all are odd no matter where you
start you cannot traverse all those
bridges along comes World War two bomber
attacks horrible just desperately
horrible situation two of these bridges
get destroyed the town's devastated but
at the end of the war there's five
bridges left so in a sense today there's
no seven bridges of königsberg anymore
not only are there not seven bridges the
city of conness burg doesn't exist it's
been renamed to Kaliningrad it's a part
of Russia today where I think the Baltic
Fleet works out of there and there's
five bridges well suppose you're sitting
around in today's city could you do this
well before even trying let's just note
C over here note C this land mass of C
has two bridges today an even number
over there landmass be the blue one has
one two bridges from it what about
island a one two three bridges in odd
number Island e one two three bridges Oh
thus today there is no problem from what
oiler said we could start on either of
the odd bridged islands so I can start
here and I'll end there I have to choose
a path that takes me from here to there
okay I'll go like this buh-buh-buh-buh
crossed one bridge cross two bridge I'll
walk across my third bridge backwards
walk across the fourth bridge forwards
back to where I started but wait there's
one more bridge buh buh buh buh I've
traversed the entire path started there
ended there Euler has told us that if
there are exactly two islands that have
an odd number of bridges you have to
start on one of them and an end on the
other one if there were three islands
the head each had an odd number of
bridges no way you couldn't solve the
problem however if each island had an
even number of bridges suppose suppose
next week there's an earthquake in the
Baltic Sea it knocks down one one bridge
now every landmass has two bridges going
to it and even I can figure it out oh
yeah I can traverse um well here's the
first one here's the second one
here's the third one here's the fourth
way traverse them all without any
problem at all okay suppose we only have
three bridges today another earthquake
happens ah another bridge falls down now
island a has one bridge leading to it an
odd number see sure or North Shore B has
two bridges leading to it even D over
here island e has two bridges and see
where I'm standing has only one bridge
on it in this case Euler tells us yes we
can still make a circuit that crosses
all three bridges but we have to start
on an odd numbered place and end on an
odd number so I'm on the odd-numbered
see there's only one bridge one is an
odd number okay pop-up got to Dedes an
even one oh okay I'll walk across this
one Bop and then I get to be ant Oh
ha ziggety I can walk across this I end
up on an odd bridged Island
completely traversed it if all the
islands have an even number of bridges
even everywhere
then we're even-steven piece of cake you
can make this Traverse and everybody in
the saloon and their Sunday walks
they're happy what if there's only one
odd-numbered island turns out you can't
make such a thing if I have considered
just one bridge I have an island here oh
it's got an odd number of bridges but oh
here's a second island that has an odd
number of bridges I can't yeah I could
sort of send it up into the air or I
could have you know goes out into the
water you walk the plank but no for a
legitimate bridge if there's one odd
there has to be another matching
somewhere on the graph so Euler showed
that these this bridge problem is kind
of cool so if you're in a saloon or
you're going on a Sunday walk it's nice
to know oh I can or can't complete the
circuit who cares
well you can't pick up a book on
discrete mathematics discrete
mathematics and it's applications
discrete mathematics and computer
science discrete mathematics with ducks
you can't touch a book on this without
turning to a page that has wheeler on it
and sure enough over here the Swiss
mathematician Leonhard Euler solve this
problem blablablablabla Euler invented
graph theory this is the first time 1830
that graph theory has been thought of
and instead of analyzing this as a let's
walk across bridges Euler recognized
that that connections from one place to
another were central to a part of
mathematics even cooler than that oiler
said this is a geometric problem that
has no triangles it doesn't have
hypotenuse is in it it's what he called
a geometry problem of location this was
the beginning of topology
Oyler solution for this created graph
theory Oilers solution to this created
topology uh all this from from a guy who
oh yeah
I've got a little bit of time to think
about a problem that I heard about from
people going on Sunday walks that's
brilliance
thank you to audible for supporting this
video audible is the top provider of
audiobooks and other spoken material
with a dizzying number of titles
covering almost anything you can think
of if you don't believe me here are just
seven bridge books you might enjoy
listening to bridge of spires the ice
bridge Bridge to Terabithia a bridge too
far the invisible bridge Bridget Jones's
Diary
and my personal favorite on this list
the Great Bridge the epic story of the
building of the Brooklyn Bridge and I've
just said bridge a lot of times if you'd
like to listen to these or any other
books from audible you can sign up for a
free month trial which will include your
first book for no charge audibles a
great service they've got a super app
via phone and it's really easy to
exchange a book if you end up with one
that doesn't take your fancy to give
them a try go to audible.com slash
numberphile that way they'll know you
came from here and now thanks to them
for supporting this video